INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
So in today's video, we're going
to talk about something that
maybe on the surface
isn't as exciting as some
of the other topics
in machine learning,
but it is the fundamental
component of it.
If you think back to
what we talked about as
far as what we define
as machine learning,
we broke it down into two camps,
there was supervised learning
and unsupervised learning.
If we start with unsupervised
learning for a second,
again, that is a
situation where I don't
have any labels about the data.
I might have a bunch of
data about my customers,
but I don't really know
what group they fall into
or maybe the customer
profile of them.
I might be looking for patterns
or trends amongst them,
but those patterns are going to
be absent any label that says,
definitively this person is
between the ages of 25 and 34.
If I wanted to know if they were
between the ages of 25 and 34,
I would have to label
them in some way.
So that might be implicit
in the process, that
might be a data point we
collect about the user
when they sign up.
But what if it isn't?
What if it's something where I
just get the web traffic that
comes to my site and I don't
know anything about those users?
Well, if I want to label that
data, then I need to go in there
or have a human go
in there and manually
decide which person
falls into which bucket.
Maybe that means linking their
account with their web traffic
with a specific account
or something like that.
Or let me get maybe more
specific to the problem
that we're going
to work on today.
Let's say that we are
trying to design a model
or build a model that can
predict what is in an image.
You could imagine
all the use cases
for identifying
what's in an image.
But let's take
something that's really
an issue we're facing today
and that's self-driving cars.
With self-driving cars, I need
to know what object is what.
I need to know that
that's a car next to me,
I need to know that that's
a motorcycle, a cyclist,
a pedestrian walking across
the street in 18 Wheeler.
All those things might
imply different actions.
It might say, well, I know
the speed that this thing will
likely be able to move at.
I'll know the rough size of it,
even if I only see part of it.
And so that means that I
need to be able to detect
what is in that image.
And so because I want to know
exactly what's in that image,
I need to train a
supervised learning
model, meaning that I need to
have labels on my data set.
Because I might have cars
that are out there in the wild
that are taking countless
images of the environment,
but until it knows
what's in the image,
it doesn't know
what's in the image.
It's this Catch-22.
So we have to take those images
then and almost always we
pass those off to a real human
and have that human then go in
and say, OK, this is a
motorcycle, this is a car,
this is a plane, a bus, a goat,
a giraffe, whatever it is,
whatever our task at hand is.
And so this process
of data labeling
is what we're going
to talk about today.
How do we go about
actually doing that?
How do we create these
labels in the images?
I'm trying to close
out my downloads here
so we have maximum screen space.
So to that end, let's look at
what we want to label today.
So I'm going to start with
coming up here to Canvas,
and so on Canvas
under the Files tab,
I created this folder
here called images,
and in there there's 10 images.
You can see they're just
images of different objects,
a helicopter, boat,
car, another boat.
And you'll see they're all
different angles, viewpoints,
types of objects, but they
share similar categories.
And so now the question
is, how do I train a model?
How do I train a
machine learning?
Oh, I realize I'm blocking
the way of my videos
here, let me shrink
myself, by the way, first.
There we go.
So now you can see what
I'm actually talking about.
So sorry once again.
You can see here files and
under files, under the images,
this is where we have all
these object or image objects.
And so again, we want to
know what's in these images.
We know that machine
learning, if it's given
labeled data, if
it's given examples,
then we can train a
supervised learning model
to predict what's
in these images.
But it still has to
know that ground truth
of well, what is in the image.
And so this is where
we're going to do.
And so this data sets a
publicly available data set,
we only took a sample
of 10 images here,
but it's called the
Caltech 101 data set.
And so you can see here it has,
I don't know how many total
images, download size 120
megabytes, 101 images,
9,000 images there.
So we have 9,000 images
total in this data set,
we're only going to focus on
10 for now to keep the problem
small.
But the reality is if I want to
be able to have the best model,
I need to have as many
labeled images as possible,
and 9,000 is arguably on the
very small end of what we work
with today.
Some of the more
popular data sets
are on the order of millions,
if not billions of data points.
Or think about
something like Tesla,
they have their cars
out in the wild.
I won't get into debate on,
whether they're self-driving
or not.
Take one of my
other classes where
I talk about how self-driving
cars actually work and you
can have a bit more
of a discussion there.
But let's just take it at
face value for a second
that they do have cars
that are out in the wild
collecting a bunch
of training data
or better still collecting
a bunch of data,
and actually they're
collecting video data.
And each car, I think has
something like let's say
a half dozen cameras in
the visible spectrum.
Those cameras maybe are
recording at something
like 30 frames per second.
And so I love my back
of the envelope math,
let's do some back of the
envelope math for a second.
So if I have 30 frames
per second times,
how much does the average
person drive per day?
Let's say an hour, 30
minutes to work and back.
So let's say 30 frames
per second times
60 seconds times 60 minutes
times 6 unique cameras.
And that means that
each individual person,
if they're driving
an hour per day,
would be collecting
648,000 frames of video,
which each frame could arguably
be treated as an image.
So even just from
one person driving
each day, we would
have technically about
or at least half a million
images from one of these cars.
Now, obviously, a lot of
those are duplicates and maybe
aren't much of a
change in the scenery,
but the point still stands.
If I want to have the
best model possible,
I should give it
the most examples.
And so again, that's half a
million images from one person
to label.
How many Tesla's
are sold in a year?
I don't maybe 100,000,
something like that.
If we multiply that out, it
pretty quickly jumps up 100,000
million, so we're at 64.8
million or sorry, billion.
That's 100,000, 64.8 billion
images per day that they could
technically have.
So you can see the scale
of this problem in that.
If I wanted to label
all images, that
would become
prohibitively expensive.
So we obviously don't label
everything, but the question
and actually I've been asked
this question too many times
in my life, but
it's a fair question
to ask is, if I am the data
scientist and I'm asked to
or tasked with
predicting or training
a model that can predict
what's in an image,
the question is, how
many images do I need?
How many images
do I need to have
labeled to be able to do this?
And my answer is almost
always as many as you have,
as many as you're willing to
label because the more we have,
the better it gets.
That has been the
truth across the board.
And the more difficult the task
is, the more labeled examples
I need.
So all that is to say
we have to label images
and so here is one
way we can do that
in a somewhat efficient way.
And again, the important
thing here being
that we need a
human in the loop to
do that effectively, or at least
with some level of reliability.
So like I said, these
images are on Canvas here
under this files folder.
If you want to follow along,
you by no means have to.
And actually, for that matter,
as we get into the process,
we'll see the cost
of these tasks.
And then you can
decide at that point
if you want to
actually run them.
So I'll tell you at what
point, anything you click
is going to start charging you.
But either way, it's going
to be a really low cost
for now anyways, but
just know that there
is an associated cost.
But this is more to be
used as a reference for you
so you can understand
the process
and you can always
come back to it.
But again, if you do
want to follow along,
download this folder
of images here,
you'll probably get
zipped up, so you'll just
need to unzip them, and
then upload them to S3.
So I have them
currently uploaded
in the data3600demo bucket under
ground truth demo, under images,
and these are these 10 images.
Now again, you'll need to
do this on your own account,
I don't believe you'll
have permissions to do
this on the university account.
So again, everything
from here on out,
we're just doing on
your own account.
So either way, if we come in
here, got those images there.
So now what we want to do is
actually do the labeling task.
So to do that, we are
going to come into--
trying to find my
step of the notes,
I skipped past a
few things here.
There we go.
So let's go into the
search bar and we're
going to search for SageMaker
and wait for that to load up.
There we go.
And so SageMaker is a hub of
everything machine learning
for AWS.
So building training, deploying
machine learning models,
it's all going to
happen in here.
On the left hand side, you'll
see that there's this ground
truth tag here, dropdown menu.
We're going to
click Labeling jobs.
So under Labeling
jobs, you'll see
that I already have a completed
job and for that matter,
we're going to come back
and look at this one
because I don't want to
have to run another one
to label the same 10
images, but we'll at least
get up to that step.
So we'll come to
create labeling jobs,
and so let's say we want to call
it a vehicle labeling job 2.
You can name it whatever
you want to name it.
Now we have a choice
here, and we're
going to leave this
unchecked here.
But we have a choice here
of doing an automated data
setup or a manual data setup.
What's basically
going to happen is
we're going to tell the
S3 bucket of our data set,
and it's going to
go in there and it's
going to create a
manifest, a JSON file that
is a manifest of all of
the images, their location,
and the folder structure if
there is any specific folder
structure that
needs to be known.
This is going to be
used once we actually
deploy this labeling job.
We could also do a
manual data setup, where
we specify the input
data set location,
output data set
location, basically,
where we want the labels to go.
Actually, I think we might
have to specify that still.
Yeah, we still have
to specify that.
But basically, it'll remove
some of the automated steps that
are going to happen.
So we're going to do the
automated setup, though.
And so we'll browse S3 for
a location of our data sets.
So we'll do data3600demo.
And then where did I go here?
ground-truth-demo, and Images.
So actually, let's
go back in here.
We just need to click Images.
I think we want to
do it at that level.
Yeah.
So let's select that.
And so that's going to be
the input data set location.
And then we want to have
the output labels go
to a different location.
And for that matter,
let me make sure
that I don't have something.
Actually, it doesn't matter.
It's not a big deal.
We're not going
to run it anyways.
But we're going to do
output data set location.
And so I'm just copying
and pasting this,
but I'm going to change
this to say labeled-data2.
That's where I'm going to
tell it to go to-- the bucket.
I'm going to tell it to go to
The data type here,
as we said, there
are images, so we can
just tell it that.
But you see here, it has
automated data setup features
for text, video,
and video frames.
So you can do any of those.
And then as far as the role
that we need, let me see,
I think we need to create
a new role for this.
Let's do Create a New Role.
And we're just saying, it can
have access to any S3 bucket
because we're letting it set
it up anywhere it needs to.
OK.
And Then now we can--
I don't think we need
anything here just yet.
Yeah.
So this is just if you want
to not label all the images.
You want to label a random
sample or a specific subsample
of it.
For now, we're saying, we want
everything labeled, if possible.
So we'll do Complete Data Setup.
And you'll see, it actually
has a loading step here,
because what's happening now
is it's going in and creating
that manifest file.
So if I go to S3 really
quick, let me open up S3.
Let's go here.
S3.
And if we go into data3600demo,
ground-truth-demo, Images,
you'll see that,
today's November 27,
it just created this
manifest file here.
And so again, this manifest
file just tells it information
or it contains this information
about the files that
are in this folder.
So coming back here
then, we can now
come down to some more
information about the task type.
So in here, we obviously
are doing image.
We already told it that.
But now, you can select
what specific task.
So this will be an
image classification
task with a single label.
So we can leave
this one checked.
But it's the
equivalent of saying,
what is the thing in this image?
Though, arguably, this can
be a little bit fuzzy because
for example, even
in this image, yes,
maybe if the two choices
were basketball or soccer,
the label is basketball.
But be mindful that when we
train the machine learning
model, it doesn't know what part
of this image is basketball.
So if maybe all of our
examples of basketball
were images taken in a city,
and all of our images of soccer
were images taken in a
rural area or an area
that is away from
buildings, it might
learn to just
associate basketball
with buildings and soccer
with blue open skies.
That is obviously not
what we want it to learn.
So single label classification
can have that outcome
if you don't have a good
representative data set.
For now, we'll take this
as gospel and go with it,
but be mindful of that issue.
Moving on to multilabel
classification.
And we'll just talk
about what each of these
are really quickly here, so you
know what they're talking about.
Multilabel classification
is arguably a bit more
appropriate of a task, though,
it's more time-consuming,
because multilabel
classification says,
well, here's a
long list of things
that could be in the image.
Just check what all the
things are in the image.
Now, it still might be the
case that you don't include
the right category
because maybe, again,
you don't include
building as an option.
And so therefore, that
doesn't get picked up
as something that
could be in the image.
But it's at least a little bit
more verbose or a little bit
more detailed of a task.
But again, downside here
is that we're not only
going to be susceptible to
any classes or any categories
that we didn't
include, but also, it's
going to be more time-consuming.
And as we go down
this list, everything
is basically getting more
and more time-consuming,
which means it's
going to cost us more
to get the labels for this.
OK, that's image
classification multilabel.
Next step down is
bounding boxes.
So this is now saying, OK,
can you identify not only
potentially, what the object is,
but also draw a box around it?
And drawing this
box around it, now,
lets me do something
really much more valuable.
So again, thinking about the
self-driving car scenario.
I not only need to know that
there's a car in the image,
I need to know where
that car is in the image
and how much of the
frame it's taking up.
Because if it's taking
up a lot of space,
that means the car is very close
to me versus if it's taking up
a small amount of space,
that car is very far
and everything's OK.
So the bounding box can
arguably be much more important
than anything else.
So either way, that's
the next one up, though.
Again, it does take
more time to label.
And then finally, the most
time-consuming labeling task
is semantic segmentation.
As you can see in this
image, that's not only
just identifying
what the object is,
but also outlining
the exact shape of it.
So I know exactly
which pixels are
associated with car versus
person or purse versus phone.
Now, it has another
byproduct, and this same issue
happens with bounding
box as well too, is that,
again, if I don't include
a category for buildings,
it just gets lumped into
the background class.
And everything that's not one
of the known labels or one
of the provided
choices for a label
is just lumped in as
the background class.
Now, the reality of this is from
a practical machine learning
standpoint, what
we're really doing
is predicting what every
pixel is in this image.
And then we'll connect
contiguous regions
into an object, let's say.
So we would go down this
image, one pixel at a time.
And as we're coming
through here, all of these
are background.
But as we start to
hit this woman's hair,
we would say, OK, this pixel
is associated with person.
And so we're going
to color it pink.
We're just going to
identify this as person.
And we're just going to
keep going through here,
identifying each pixel, and then
connecting contiguous regions.
Again, this is super, super
time-consuming to label.
So it's really hard to get
large data sets with this,
though, these are the most
valuable, because again,
if I have semantic
segmentation, I
can reconstruct all
of these labels.
I could know what
the bounding box is.
I can know what
the multi-label is.
I could even potentially cut
it down to a single label
if there's only one
object in the image.
Semantic segmentation
is also something
that you guys have probably
used pretty frequently.
If you have a portrait
mode on your phone,
like on your cell phone to take
images with, where it blurs out
the background to create this
kind of dramatic photography,
nice bokeh effect, that
is semantic segmentation.
It's predicting
whether each pixel
is foreground or background.
Anything foreground,
it leaves in focus.
Anything background,
it artificially blurs,
creating that depth
of field effect.
So again, all of these are
really practical things,
but they increase in time
that it takes to get them.
The one last one here
that we can choose from
is label verification.
Now, label verification
is just saying, OK, well,
what if we already have labels?
What if somebody
went through and did
one of these labeling tasks.
Can I now have another
person go through
and just verify whether
that's true or not?
Arguably, if I had multiple
people go through this over
and over and verify it,
first off, verifying labels
is much faster than
making new labels.
For example, with the semantic
segmentation, I could just say,
well, is this object correctly
outlined as car, yes or no?
And if it's yes or if the
vast majority of people
say yes that do the
label verification task,
then I can just
accept that as, OK,
that's probably ground truth.
That's an OK label.
And so that is another
really useful step
that can be very valuable.
So again, long winded
way to say, let's
stick with image classification
with a single label for now.
And then once we've done
that, we'll just click Next.
And everything up to this point,
if you've been following along,
is not charging us.
Again, I'll tell you
once you actually have
to worry about the charging.
So now, we can scroll
back up to the top
here once we've gotten
to the next screen.
And now is actually
the choice of how
we go about doing the labeling.
So if we start with private.
Private is probably
the simplest one
to think about that's
saying, Hey, I'm
going to go ahead and
do the labeling here.
Maybe my team is going
to do the labeling.
So just set up all
the architecture
for us to go in here and
actually do the task.
That is useful if you have a
team that can do the labeling
or maybe if you have a very
specialized or sensitive task
where you need that data to
stay within your organization.
But again, it's going to require
the most resources on your end.
Now, there's also,
though, and we're not
going to really talk
about vendor-managed,
this is a separate
thing that, again,
if you need vendor-managed,
you'll use it.
I mean, obviously, you can
read what it does here,
curated list of
third party vendors
that specialize in providing
data labeling services.
But arguably, more useful
is Amazon's Mechanical Turk.
This is a special case of the
vendor-managed in that this
is built into Amazon.
And so what Mechanical Turk
does, and actually, we actually
talked about this in one
of the previous lectures,
but as a refresher, at least,
it is effectively gig work.
It's a gig economy,
the same as you
have with an Uber or
something like that,
except rather than them
driving you around,
it's a bunch of people.
You can see here, they have over
500,000 independent contractors
worldwide that are just waiting
and ready to do these types
of tasks or these
low level tasks.
This is used very
often in research
because it's an easy
way to get a lot of data
created from humans without
having to recruit new humans.
You just pay them per task,
and you can access that.
So that's the one I used to
do this demo in this class.
So now, once we've
selected that, you can see,
we can first specify
how long before--
or how much time can a worker
spend on a single task.
This is not saying that we
are necessarily paying them
for the whole five minutes they
could potentially spend there,
but maybe it's
something where we
don't want them to have infinite
amount of time researching it.
Or maybe it's
something where I need
them to make really quick
responses to simulate something.
And so I can constrain
the task time out here.
And similarly, I can specify
the expiration time, so
the amount of time that a task
remains available to workers
before expiring.
So both of these are
intertwined in that sense.
But more important here
is this price per task.
This price per task is
how much you're actually
going to be paying
the Mechanical Turk
worker to do the task.
So in our case, a task would
be labeling a single image.
So looking at one
of our images here,
if we just click
into one of them.
So asking the user to say,
what is in this image?
Is it car, motorcycle,
plane, boat?
That task there is one task.
And how much do you want to pay
for that is listed right here.
So you can see,
they have basically
recommended guidelines based off
of the complexity of the task.
So this would definitely
fall into a low complexity
task, where with
five or six labels,
it's going to be
relatively quick to do,
easily can be done
in five seconds.
And so they say, an appropriate
amount is 0.12 cents.
You can do the math out, right?
So if it takes five
seconds to do that,
that means you could do what?
Times 2, times 6, so
12 of those per minute.
So 12 times 5 seconds
will give us 60 seconds.
So in one minute, you
could do, conceivably,
if it took five
seconds on average,
12 tasks, times 0.012 cents
is 14.4 cents per minute,
times 60 minutes
is $8.64 per hour.
And so that is the
rate that they're
charging for that or the
rate at which they're
scaling that or paying that.
So you can pay it at that rate.
And obviously, also, the more
you're willing to pay for it,
the more likely, potentially,
somebody is to take on the task.
But either way, that's what
a low complexity task is.
And you see, they have increased
that as it goes up here.
On the high end, things are
taking about three minutes,
they're paying about
$1.20 per task.
So we'll leave it
at that for now.
Then first off, we need
to declare or check
to specify whether it
contains adult content or not,
because obviously,
that's necessary to know.
I don't even think they'll
allow you to label it.
Or yeah, they'll at
least warn their workers
if there is adult
content in there.
So make sure to
specify that if it's
potentially in there or not.
We need to specify
that you understand
that it's an independent
contractors, so
don't share confidential
information,
personal information, or
protected health information.
You see, it won't even let me
work without unchecking it.
And there's also this step here
of automated data labeling.
So if you think your
tasks are simple enough
or your objects
are simple enough,
and you are willing to trust
their machine learning models
to automatically label
them, then you can do that.
I would argue that if
their models can do that,
I wouldn't pay to do
that because there likely
exists one publicly
available for free
that you could use
to do your labeling.
So it's up to you if you
want to do that or not,
but I'm going to ignore that.
You can also specify the number
of workers per data set object.
So the more people that do
the task, the more reliable
your results could be.
Because basically,
you can vote them
or you can at least see
the confidence in them.
If all three people think
it's the same thing,
then it's going be
100% confident versus
if only one person thinks it's
that-- or if each person thinks
it's a different object, then
it might be only 33% confidence
in any one of those.
So that's one way to increase
the reliability of your labels.
Though, recognize,
you're obviously
going to pay multiples.
So if I have 10 images
at 0.12 cents per task,
yeah, that's going to
be 12 cents per task--
or 12 cents, sorry, for
the whole list of images.
And then times 3 will give me
36 cents to label all of these.
So coming down
here then, now, you
can specify the
actual tasks at hand.
So first, you want
to add your labels.
So in this data set, there's
airplanes, cars, boats--
or I'll say, boat, sorry,
singular, helicopter,
or motorcycle.
And here's just a sample.
You can see all 10 of
our images here, though,
arguably, if we had
more, it'll just
give us a subsample of them.
You can also come in here
and provide good example
versus bad examples
for your labeler
so they have
references to go to.
And for that matter, you can
also provide instructions, so
additional instructions.
Because for example, choose
the appropriate label
that best suits the image.
But then I would say
also, maybe if there
are multiple vehicles
in a single image,
please choose the most
prominent vehicle in the image.
So that'll give my labelers
more information about what
is possible in this data set.
Now, finally, you can
click the Create Task.
Now, this is where it's going
to actually start charging you.
So if you click this, be
mindful that it will charge you.
So I'm not going to click it now
because I've already done this
once before, so there's no
reason to duplicate this work
and pay twice for it, even
though it is only 30 cents.
So I'm just going to
click Cancel for now.
But if you had clicked
Create, then it
would come into status
here of In Progress.
So I think it says In Progress.
And it'll tell you how
many labeled objects there
are already.
And it'll take some time.
So it's not an
instantaneous thing.
I think when I did
this, it took probably
like four or five minutes before
all 10 images were labeled.
Though, I'd argue, that's
still pretty impressive
that I was able to reach
out to a global workforce,
get them to accept my task, and
have three people each label
one of the images
or one of our tasks
here, and thereby,
creating this label set.
So it's a really cool
resource in that sense.
But let's click in here and
see what the output looks like.
So you see, there is
my input data set.
There is an output
data set location.
And that is actually
contains all the labels.
And it basically
contains a JSON file
with all the labels in there.
I don't think I've deleted it
yet, so it may still be in here.
If we come down to
Manifests and Output,
we'll just click into this.
Click Open really quick.
And then let me open
this JSON file for you.
So you can see, this is
basically what it returns.
I don't want to open
it in that software,
it's going to take forever.
Here we go.
It just returns this
JSON to you with the name
of the object, the label,
as well as the confidence.
But as you see
here, the confidence
isn't always that high.
So for example, some
of these is 72%.
I think one of them,
yeah, down here was 27%.
This was image 0271.
So let's look at this one.
Image 0271.
The predicted label
for this one is--
where are we at here?
Yeah, the predicted
label was Ferry.
So that was the other kind
of boat I added as ferry.
But either way, it predicted
that motorcycle is a ferry.
And then the confidence
here was 0.27.
So not very high
confidence at all,
which is good because it's
very much not a ferry.
But it is the reality
of getting labeled data.
And this is also why, if you're
using this for downstream tasks,
you want to increase the number
of workers that you have,
because you never know what
differences might be there.
I also didn't provide examples
of what each class was.
I just gave them these
images and assumed that they
knew what a ferry was.
There are cultural
differences in this world that
results in language
barriers, potentially,
that maybe result in different
names meaning different things.
And so this is something
you have to be mindful of
and why it'd be very
important if you're
doing this in practice, to
give great examples of what
each possible object
could look like.
But either way,
once you have that,
you at least have
your labeled images
here that now, we could use
for some downstream task
to make our predictions.
Once you have done that,
if you are interested
or if you followed along with
that, feel free to go ahead
and delete any files
that were created
or delete it from the
S3 bucket, because you
will be paying for
anything that's
still stored in your S3 bucket.
But if you are just
watching along,
then you should be good to go.
And now, leverage this
tool in the future.
Again, this is something that
is very, very widely used.
I've read countless papers
that have used this as a source
for labeling data.
I've worked at many
companies, where
we are given some massive
data set from our customer.
And they want to know what's in
the images, or better statement,
they want to be able to
predict what might be
in those images in the future.
So for example, in one
of my previous jobs,
I was working with a lot
of satellite imagery.
And we had countless images.
I mean, you can imagine,
each of these satellites
is circling the world
every 90 minutes.
So we're just getting
unbelievable amounts of data.
And if I'm trying to identify
cars, and boats, and planes
in these images, I
can't physically even
hire enough people to do this
task on an ongoing basis.
But I can leverage
Mechanical Turk
or similar labeling
services to do that.
So that's the idea behind this.
That's the usefulness of this.
And it's such a critical part
of the Machine Learning process
that I couldn't leave
it out for this.
So we'll leave that here now.
In the next class, we'll
get to the step beyond this.
Once we have our data, once
we have our label data,
how do we go about actually
creating Machine Learning models
in the cloud?
OK.
Thanks for watching.
And I'll talk to you next time.
Bye.